BRENDAN BURNS: Hi there.
It's great to see
everybody out here.
I'm excited to talk to you
about Kubernetes today.
I'm Brendan Burns.
I'm a software
engineer at Google.
There's going to be a couple
other people coming up
over the course, and they'll
introduce themselves.
So you heard a little bit about
Kubernetes in the keynote,
and so hopefully if you
hadn't heard about it before,
you've got a little
bit of context.
We're going to go a little
bit deeper today and try
and explain both where we're
coming from, why we built it,
and what's the new awesomeness
that we just built.
So I wanted to take a
little bit of a step
back and give you a little
bit of the history of where
we came from.
Eric went into this a
little bit this morning,
so we're going to kind of move
through it relatively quickly,
so you don't get bored.
Hopefully you saw some of
that stuff in the opening
keynote today.
But, in some sense,
Google, a long time
ago, exactly like the
way a lot of enterprise
and a lot of other
data centers are now,
every single app
had its own machine.
You would use
ticketing and things
like that to find machines.
It was hard to manage,
hard to scale, painful
for people to operate.
And so we started
to figure out, well,
what do we need to do in order
to move away from the sort
of one-app-per-machine model?
And the very beginnings of
that were things like chroots,
using [? Nice, ?] using some
of the traditional things that
allow you to
multi-tenant things.
But it wasn't sufficient, right?
Noisy neighbors are
a significant problem
in that world, where some
intern running a MapReduce
can totally obliterate
your search infrastructure,
and that's just not an
acceptable way to run things.
And so moving
forward, we started
to develop technology that
enabled us to have better
isolation of these processes.
And that eventually led
to things like cgroups
that Google contributed
to the Linux kernel.
And what we found eventually was
that actually these isolation
boundaries really
helped us maximize
the utilization of the
machines to the point where
our utilization of machines is
significantly higher than that
of people basically throughout
the rest of the industry.
And it's not necessarily
because the people who
use the machines are smarter
about packing things,
but it's actually just so
we have better isolation
and that enables us
to practice for them.
And that's really
what Kubernetes
is trying to do as well.
So then, eventually,
Docker came around
and took a lot of
these technologies
and packaged them up in
a really amazing way.
And Eric said that the container
image that Docker came around
with and the building
tools around that
really sort of opened up
the world of containers
and some of the
value of containers
on the node to
the broader world.
And suddenly we saw this
explosion of interest
in containers.
It was really gratifying,
I think, for a lot of us
because suddenly all of the
stuff that we had been talking
about and thinking
about internally,
we could share with
the outside world.
And so the time was right.
About a little under
two years ago, the time
was right to start sharing
some of the experiences we'd
had over the
proceeding eight years
and to start listening
as well, right?
We were starting to build
out the cloud platform,
and we knew that our
own internal experience
wasn't necessarily
the same as where
our users were coming from.
And so we wanted to go forth
with this project and share
what we knew, but
also accept and build
a community around
where people were.
And that led to the
development of Kubernetes.
Kubernetes, it's an open source
container management system.
Again, you heard about it
this morning from Eric,
so I don't want to
belabor the point.
And you, actually, hopefully,
saw the demo as well in
the keynote yesterday.
It supports multiple
cloud environments.
It supports on-prem
physical machines.
It supports the
Raspberry Pi cluster
that I have in my closet.
And it's 100% open source.
It's written in Go.
If you haven't checked out Go,
it's a pretty fun language.
So that by itself is
worth checking out.
And it's all available
out on GitHub.
The core principles
of Kubernetes-- I
think this is really important.
When we were going
into it, we really
wanted to talk about what
we are trying to accomplish
when we built Kubernetes.
And part of what we were
trying to accomplish
is that we knew that
people were going
to be using-- unlike in Google,
where everything is built
from source, people are going
to take off-the-shelf software.
They're going to take MySQL.
They're going to take Nginx.
They're going to put them
in containers and run them.
And rewriting those applications
just isn't an option for users.
And then the other
important principle
it runs throughout Kubernetes is
that coupling is really, really
bad.
When you take systems and you
package them together tightly
and so they're
tightly coupled, you
end up making changes
in one place that
break things in another place
that you weren't anticipating.
And that leads to instability.
It leads to an inability to
move your software forward--
all of the things that
are necessary to build
a scalable, agile
platform that go away
if you couple your software
really tightly together.
So we really wanted to
decouple our software.
And then there's a lot about
making sure that we are open.
We really saw that this
open infrastructure
movement was happening.
It was something that was
important to participate in.
You're even starting to see
this on the hardware side,
on the data center design
side, with Facebook
and others participating in
open data center designs.
It's just that's the way that
the data centers of the future
are going to be built, and
we wanted to be part of that.
And then also, what
I like to say--
I don't know if people
have had a chance to take
a look at the Kubernetes paper
that we published recently.
But one of the
key insights there
is that Kubernetes and
container-clustered
orchestration
systems really allow
you to change the primary
key of your data center
from being the machine to
being the application, right?
We want people to start really
forgetting about machines
and thinking about
applications instead.
And so all of this sort of
says we have experienced
a lot of the things that
are bothering people
right now out there in
software development.
And we've built some
solutions that we really
believe help you move
on, and this is an image
that I use it a lot of my talks,
and I think it really captures,
in some sense, what we're
trying to accomplish.
The challenge of
driving something
like this semi truck that
crashed in the middle
here is the semi truck is
a coupled system, right?
There is the cab that is
pulling it and the trailer.
And as anybody's who's
backed up a trailer knows,
you can be backing
up in one direction,
and your trailer can
be going in completely
the opposite direction, right?
That coupling, that
unintended consequence
of some action-- because rarely
do you take actions that you
think are going to fail, right?
Rarely do you,
like, push a config
because you know that
it's bad, and it's
going to cause your
application to go down.
But the reason you have
all those failures related
to human error is that there's
an unanticipated consequence.
And that unanticipated
consequence almost always
comes from this
kind of coupling.
And to illustrate this
a little bit more,
when you think about things
in a machine-oriented way,
when your data center
is machine-oriented
and you think about
physical infrastructure,
you end up with
things like this,
where services are
splattered across three
different machines.
And when you think
about the machine,
you think, oh, OK, I
really need to upgrade libC
on machine number one,
because my back end needs
this new version of libC.
And so you go in and you
upgrade libC on machine one,
and your back end is
like, I'm awesome.
I'm happy to go.
And then it turns
out your front ends
all crashed because they
use that library too,
but they use a slightly
different version
of that library, and
there's a bug in the library
that you just upgraded that
caused them to start crashing.
That's the unintended
consequence, right?
That's why coupling
in this world is bad.
And so what we would
really like to do
is show you how Kubernetes
enables you to create what
we call logical infrastructure.
And logical
infrastructure basically
says, forget about
the machines, right?
The machines disappear
below the Kubernetes API,
below this unified substrate.
And you start thinking
about your applications.
It's an application-oriented
infrastructure.
All of your front
ends are the same.
The thing that you're going
to change is your front end.
to upgrade is your front end.
And in this way, you've
decoupled all of these systems
from one another,
and you don't have
those unintended consequences
that cause stability problems.
Another really important
part of being open and being
transparent is this idea of
workload portability, right?
There's all sorts of
reasons for people
to be in multiple
kinds of data centers,
be at their own
on-prem data centers,
private cloud, public
cloud, co-location,
whatever it happens to be.
There's a lot of
reasons why you're
going to be in a lot
of different places.
And we profoundly believe
that the future of cloud
is hybrid, right?
And so in that world, it's
important to have a system that
spans these things
and enables you
to move your application from
vendor to vendor, if they're
having stability problems,
if they're having pricing
that you don't like,
if a different vendor
comes along and has
better pricing, whatever
the motivation happens to be.
Not being locked into
a particular vendor
by using their APIs is
really powerful for you
as an end user.
And Kubernetes, with its open
source aspect and its ability
to run anywhere, means
if you write applications
to the Kubernetes APIs, those
APIs are available and can
move with you wherever
you choose to go,
or indeed can normalize
your environment as well.
And so this comes down
to the sort of idea
of write once, run
anywhere, which, by now,
kind of has sort of
a bad reputation,
I guess, at some level
because, of course,
there's the asterisks, right?
This is mostly true.
This isn't 100% true.
But really, if you build in a
container, which encapsulates
all of its dependencies into
this hermetically sealed box
and you deploy and
you use services
provided by the
Kubernetes API, you really
are targeting a run
time that is pretty
independent of
the infrastructure
that it's running
on top of, right?
In the same way that if you
write a program in a higher
level language,
usually-- and that's
where the asterisk
comes in of course--
that program can run on a
variety of architectures,
from ARM in the Raspberry Pi,
to x86, to MIPS on a router,
or whatever it happens to be.
And some examples of this
inside the Kubernetes API,
where we've really try
to put in some effort
into making these
things portable,
include things like our
networking model, where
we really tried to be agnostic.
We didn't just sort of
say, like, oh, hey, this
works great on GCE.
Nobody else can do
it anywhere else.
Ingress is another
really great example
of this, where we created an
API object for doing HTTP load
balancing.
And actually the implementation
of how that actually
produces a balancer,
is developed
outside of the Kubernetes
core code base.
So if you want one for your
favorite cloud provider,
you want one for your physical
hardware load balancer,
you can build all
of these things.
And there's one API object,
but the implementation
can be in a variety
of different ways.
Our services are
examples of this as well,
as well as persistent volumes,
where, I think, at this point,
we support 12 different volume
types, different distributed
storage technologies,
different cloud storage
technologies--
really enables you
to be isolated from the
specifics of the platform
that you're running on.
And then, finally, I talk
a lot about this coupling.
We really think that
the Kubernetes API
allows you to build these
systems that are decoupled
from each other so
that you can actually
have different teams doing
rollouts at different layers.
Your front end team can roll
out a new set of the front ends
without ever communicating with
the middleware or the back end
teams at all.
Or the middleware
team can do a rollout
and never communicate with the
front end team or the back end
team.
That's hugely important for
distributed teams, for scaling
teams up, and all
of these things
are made available
by the ability
to isolate things behind a
service IP that is unchanging,
right?
It doesn't matter that
the actual pods that
implemented a particular service
have come up or gone down.
The front end still just
talks to the same service IP.
Likewise, we also want
you to be decoupled
from Kubernetes itself.
We don't want to
provide tools so
that if you have a
configuration that
looks for a particular
environment variable,
you don't have to teach Nginx
that it's running inside
of Kubernetes.
You can use things
like the downward API
to project parts of
the Kubernetes API
into environment variables
that Nginx already
knows how to consume, right?
This is part of meeting
people where they are as well
as ensuring that that
application that somebody wrote
isn't a Kubernetes version
of the application.
It's the same
application, whether it's
running inside of Kubernetes or
any other kind of environment.
And then the other
part of this is
you can do this kind of
lift and shift, right?
Like maybe you're hybrid, but
you don't want to be stuck.
If you get to a place where
the platform doesn't work,
if you're in GKE and you reach
that place where you're like,
no, we really need to be on-prem
for some reason, we'll be sad,
of course, but you
can do that, right?
You can take your
workload out of GKE,
roll it on over to
an on-prem cluster.
Or likewise, if you're in a
different public cloud provider
right now-- we
understand lots of people
use different public clouds.
You can start with Kubernetes
in that environment
and build a place
where, as we demonstrate
to the value of running inside
the Google Cloud platform,
you'll be able to easily
move that application across,
or you can gradually
move your application
from one platform to another.
And that's also a key component
of being open and being hybrid.
So that was sort
of the prehistory.
Hopefully it wasn't too
redundant with the things
that happened in the keynote.
I'd like to take a step
forward to now, to what's
next, what's going on here.
So one thing I really like to
highlight here is the velocity.
And Eric sort of mentioned
this with a high level 27,000
commits.
But this graph, I think,
really speaks to it
in a more dramatic fashion.
We're doing 46 commits a day.
And that's averaged
across the weekend,
and we don't actually do
that many commits on weekends
because we all have lives.
And so the velocity with
which we are doing this
is just amazing.
And as well, at the
same time, we're
seeing new people come
into the community.
That's fantastic as well.
Really excited to see that.
Really excited to see
all of the companies that
are contributing-- not just
using, but contributing
as well.
We really want to build a
community that isn't just
a bunch of Googlers
throwing code over the wall
but is really a
holistic community.
As part of that, you may have
also seen the announcement
that we've contributed
Kubernetes to the Cloud Native
Computing Foundation.
So the intellectual
property around Kubernetes
is now actually out and
available and available
to the Linux Foundation.
And as part of that, I want to
introduce Rich Steinberg, who's
a principle engineer
at WePay, who's
going to talk a little bit
about how they use Kubernetes
to power WePay, so Rich?
RICH STEINBERG: Thanks, Brendan.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi, I'm Rich, and
I'm going to talk
about WePay and our
experience with Kubernetes.
So WePay, I know you're going
to find it hard to believe,
but we're about payments.
We do payments.
We're startup down in
Redwood City, and what we do
is we do payments
between individuals.
We allow our partners to
build the relationship
between individuals,
and then we take
over the payment from there.
And as part of that, we
hold credit card data,
and we're PCI certified.
And we do this
using a PHP monolith
application that has been
changing the different business
models.
And now that we're
taking off like crazy,
this PHP model needs
to be taken apart.
It needs to be broken
into smaller services,
and we need a way to
deploy these services.
So we took-- let
me move forward.
So we took three servings
at this bat or this ball.
The first was we had
some bad SQL that
was running against our database
and we needed to move that off.
So we knew we
wanted to do Docker,
and we put this load
into a Docker container,
and we started it manually,
and we had it going.
It wasn't great, but
it really helped.
The second was
Ansible and deploying
to individual machines.
And we didn't really know how
to do topology at that point,
so it was really one
Docker container per VM,
and that was it.
And we were in Google
Cloud, and Kubernetes,
we were part of the community.
We were part of
the beta program.
We had developers inside
WePay that were really excited
about Kubernetes.
And as soon it became GA in
July of 2015, we were on board.
And it really dramatically
changed our whole business,
because now we're able
to spread out workload
across multiple machines.
It solved Canary deploys.
It solved being able
to rolling deployments.
It really just sort of changed
us, and it's been great.
And one of things I want to
underscore about Kubernetes
is that it's changing rapidly.
The problems and things that
we've been dealing with,
we can look at a roadmap map
and actually see features
that are going to help us.
But more than that, it
actually is real use cases
that we have problems.
So I want to talk a little
bit about some of the things
that we've done
with Kubernetes that
have been sort of outside
of what Kubernetes can do.
And then we'll go from there.
So because we're PCI
certified-- and the keynote
talked a little bit about this,
about not having a GUI center--
everything that
communicates back and forth
must be encrypted.
And that's just from the
early stages of Kubernetes
wasn't available.
So what we did is built
a sidecar in the pod
with Nginx in it, and Kube
DNS gives you a domain name.
It's like a private domain.
And we built our
own in-house CA that
served that CN as
the domain name,
and that's how we
terminated SSL.
Another example is since
we're PCI certified,
when the PCI auditors
come in, they
want to look at the smallest
number of machines possible.
They do not want to look at
hundreds and hundreds of VMs.
They want to be basically
down to the smallest [? set ?]
possible.
And in Kubernetes
terms, what that
means-- a dedicated
cluster for PCI.
And with a dedicated
cluster for PCI,
we then need two
dedicated clusters,
because we need high
availability across zones,
and so then you have
four dedicated clusters.
And these clusters need to
communicate with one another.
So there's a need for some
sort of intercluster service
discovery.
And what we're doing now
is we're jut hard coding
those service end points.
But we're looking
forward to Ubernetes,
and we've also
looked at Buoyant.
But Ubernetes is
really cool at being
able to solve this problem.
Lastly is Secrets,
and there's a lot
of talk about Secrets today.
They talked about
in the keynote.
And it's a big thing
you've got to consider.
So the way we're taking
care it at this point
is using Hashicorp
Vault. And that's
just encryption as a
service, and there's
authenticated API calls that
are scoped to the application.
So the really good
thing about this
is that it's not putting Secrets
unencrypted anywhere on disk.
It's memory-to-memory
communication,
and it's basically leased out.
So that's been sort
of some use cases.
And I want to say again that
Kubernetes doesn't really
put you into a box.
You can really kind of
do what you want with it
and take what they've given
us and build on top of it.
And at the same time,
it's constantly changing.
These problems are being
solved by the Kubernetes team.
And I'm going to
hand it over to Tim
right now to tell
you about that.
[APPLAUSE]
TIM HOCKIN: Thanks, Rich.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Tim.
I'm one of the
software engineers
working on Kubernetes.
So this is next.
So let's talk about what's next.
So I want to talk about a few
features that we're pushing out
in our Kubernetes 1.2 release
which was launched last week.
And I want to talk
in some depth,
and I'm going to
do some live demos,
and we'll tempt the fates
and see what happens.
So the first thing
that people experience
when they have these
distributed applications,
they need to figure out how am
I'm going to update this thing?
This has been a topic at
a couple of the talks.
I know Eric mentioned
it this morning.
It was part of the demo
yesterday at the keynote.
We're improving on
what we've done.
So the goal here--
run an application,
update it with zero
downtime, and zero visibility
to your end users.
We built our rolling
update process completely
on our core primitives
of Kubernetes.
There's nothing magic.
There's no back door APIs.
If you don't like the rolling
update that we've built,
you can build your own.
This comes from a direct
lesson from [? Borg, ?]
where the update system was
really built and tightly
coupled into our system.
And it turns out
updating different kinds
of applications,
there's different kinds
of requirements.
So Version 1.0 and
1.1 of Kubernetes,
we had this built into our cube
control or cube cuddle command
line.
In Version 1.2, we
have a new object
in our API called a Deployment.
And a Deployment is
updates as a service.
You tell the Deployment, I want
you to update from Version X
to Version Y, and you
take your hands off,
and the Deployment
object will do it.
It's all done server side.
You give it a bunch of
parameters that tells you
how fast you want to go and what
happens if there's a failure,
and you let it run.
If you add this with
graceful termination of pods,
what you end up with is
a clean draining update
from your system.
Any open connections, users
will finish their session,
and the old pod will go away,
and the new one will come up.
I want to walk through a
little bit of the update.
So imagine from what
you've got your service,
your wonderful MyApp.
And backing my application I've
got a replication controller
which has three pod instances
that are running it.
This is the blue version
of the application.
If you notice here,
you'll see replicas three,
and the selector is
MyApp Version 1, right?
So the first thing you're going
to do in part of an update
is you're going to bring up
a new replication controller.
Note specifically, this
is MyApp Version 2.
Now this new
replication controller,
you're going to take it
from zero replicas to one.
And now you've got a
new replica running.
The service, if you'll notice
the selector on the service,
is app MyApp.
It's version independent.
So at this point,
25% of my users
are going to be experiencing
my new application.
This gives me a
really good signal,
if I can watch my monitoring,
that maybe my application is
bad and I want to roll it back.
Well, let's assume that you got
it right, because you guys are
all smart people.
So you bring up a new one,
and you bring down an old one.
And you bring up a new one,
And you repeat this process
until the old version
of the replication controller
has zero replicas left,
and then you can
just throw it away.
Like I said, this is
all done server side now
in the Deployment
object, which you're
going to get for free if
you run cube cuddle run.
It's new in the Version 1.2 API.
The next thing people tend
to run into is scaling.
I need my application
to be responsive.
What happens if a
famous celebrity dies?
I need to be able to
respond with my application
in this change in load.
So in the Kubernetes
1.2, we have
launched something we call
the Horizontal Pod Autoscaler.
That's a mouthful.
But what it does is
it takes metrics.
Currently, we do CPU
utilization or custom metrics,
which are alpha, but they work.
You take these metrics. and you
feed it into the replication
system, and the
replication can say, hey,
you've crossed a threshold.
Let me scale you up.
Or. hey, you've dropped
below threshold.
Let me scale you down.
Obviously, you give it
some min-max bounds,
and it operates
within those bounds.
But again, you set
it, and you forget it.
This frees you from
having to worry
about what happens if something
happens in a different time
zone and you're not at a
console and you aren't there
to provision new machines.
This is the ethos of Kubernetes.
You don't have to
worry about it.
Next thing that people tend to
run into-- persistent storage,
right?
We'd like to talk about treating
your servers like cattle,
right?
Everybody knows this analogy.
Don't worry about them.
They're fungible.
If they go away,
it's not a big deal.
But the reality is somewhere
at the bottom of your stack,
you've got a database.
You've got files.
You've got storage that
you need to run your stuff.
So we have an abstraction
whole persistent volumes
in Kubernetes, which
lets you create
durable storage in
your network or on NFS
or in any one of almost two
dozen-- I'll correct Brendan.
It's not 12; it's actually a
closer to 20 different volume
types.
You store your data there.
And then as a user, you can
claim that data is yours.
So new in Kubernetes 1.2,
we have auto provisioning.
If you ask for data and there's
nothing in the system that
can satisfy that
request, we'll go off
and we'll make it for you.
Assuming you're in a cloud
provider that supports it,
like GSE or Amazon
or OpenStack, we
can automatically go out and
make this new volume for you.
What's really cool now is
you could write all your data
to this persistent
volume, and then you
can kill your
application, tear it down.
You know what?
My MySQL service is done, but
I need to offload all that data
into my monitoring system.
You can a hand off that
data to a different pod
because you still own that data.
It exists until
you're done with it.
We never destroy it until
you tell us that it's OK.
This is an application-oriented
use of infrastructure.
Don't think about the disks.
Don't think about the iSCSIs.
Don't think about where
they actually are.
Think about what you
want to do with it.
So let's do a live demo.
If we can switch
to the demo, guys.
So I have to apologize.
First of all, I cannot type
and talk at the same time.
So I have this self-typing demo.
But I promise you it is running
live against my GCE cluster
right now.
So here we go.
So this script, the first
thing I'm going to show you,
there are no claims.
PVC is a Persistent
Volume Claim.
It's a shortcut.
I'm showing you with our
cube control command,
there are no claims
in our system.
So let's go off
and create a claim.
To do this, we're going to look
at this little blob of YAML.
You can see here the claim is
called PD Provisioning Demo.
It's existing in
the Demos namespace.
What I'm asking for is something
that is read-write accessible,
and I want 10
gigabytes of space.
And so just like that,
it's been created.
And we're going to take
a look at what we've
done with the Describe command.
And it shows you here that
we have a persistent volume
claim that is already
in the bound state.
What that means is it's
already gone off and created
a volume for us and
bound it to this claim.
And it is satisfied
it with 10 gigabytes.
So this loop is actually
going to do nothing
because it happened so quickly.
So here you can
see the short form.
It happened 33 seconds ago.
That's my proof that it's real.
So here, I ran
gcloud compute disks
list, which shows me in
the Google Compute Engine,
here's the list of disks.
I grabbed for the ones that I
know that it's going to match,
and it's going to match
this dynamic disk.
So now I'm going to use this.
Again, here's a little blob
of YAML that shows me a pod.
The important part here
is what the pod does.
It does an sh -c, which says
go run this shell command.
It's going to touch a file
called /pv/ whatever my current
host name is.
We set the host name
to the pod name,
so you can see that this
file gets created on the pod,
and then it's just
going to go to sleep.
And just like that,
my pod is created,
and it's probably
already running
before I can finish
typing it out.
So you can see it's scheduled.
It's been assigned
to Minion I89N.
And we'll wait for it to give
us a running status so that we
can actually go poke at it.
OK, it is running.
So I'm going to use
to kubectl and exec
into this to give me a shell.
So I'm now live into
this running container.
If I ls in the /pv directory,
you see that this file is demo
blah-blah-blah.
That is it.
So I'm going to say-- so
I've now created this file.
So I'm going to exit the shell.
And then I'm going go ahead, and
I'm going to delete that pod.
Now this pod has
gone from the system.
That running process is
gone, just to prove it.
But my claim still exists.
I still own this data.
And it is still there,
and it is still bound.
And in Compute Engine-- maybe.
Oh, there we go.
It still exists.
So now I'm going to
run another pod, right?
My MySQL finished.
I want to go run
the post processing.
I want to analyze my
user logs or something
that I want to do here.
So I've gone and
created another pod.
And it's going to check
that it's running.
And I'm going to shell
into this one again.
And what you're
going to see-- cross
your fingers-- is that
those files that we
wrote before still exist.
So there you can see.
Now I've got two files that
are specific to the host
name and the Hello file
that I wrote before.
Now, I can do this
any number of times.
I can keep handing off
the pod from container
to container-- or the volume
from container to container
until I'm done with it.
So let me exit this, and
say I'm done with it.
So I'm going to
go delete my pod.
And you can see again
the pod is gone.
This is all happening real.
This is how fast the
system actually operates.
I've deleted my claim,
and my claim is gone.
And the persistent volume
that was backing that claim
is also gone.
And if I were to look in gcloud
which I don't think I did,
if I were to look at
gclould one more time,
it would show me that
that persistent volume
has been erased.
What this means
for you is you are
free to work on your application
and not worry about who's
managing the infrastructure,
not send a ticket to provision
a new volume.
Can you switch back
to the slides, please?
Demo number one-- it worked.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm going to tempt the
fates and do it twice.
So new also in Kubernetes
1.2-- multi-zone clusters.
You guys, you were asked, and
we heard, and we answered.
So you can now
bring up a cluster
that spans multiple zones,
GCE zones or multiple Amazon
availability zones.
We'll label the nodes that
come up on those zones.
And when you
schedule work, we're
going to spread them
across those zones.
Now, if a zone blows
up, you're safe.
Your application's
not going to go down.
Kubernetes will say, oh, damn,
what happened to those copies?
And it will bring up new
ones on these other nodes.
This is what it's all about.
2:00 AM, Sunday night,
you're sleeping.
Do you want your pager
to go off because Google
brought a zone down?
Heck no, just handle
it for me, right?
Send me email in the morning.
I'll take a look.
This is what it's about.
So there's zero changes
to the Kubernetes API.
You don't need to
know about zones.
All you need to
know is that when
you provision this cluster,
you've brought it up
in multiple zones.
This is GA in Version 1.2.
The code name for this project
has been called Ubernete.
And Ubernetes is going
to continue to evolve.
We're going to build out
a more federated cluster
model in upcoming
versions of our system.
This is what we
call Ubernetes Lite.
So the next thing that
people talk about,
and Brendan mentioned this--
Ingress, L7 load balancing.
We built the core of Kubernetes
around the idea of L3 and L4
load balancing because
we wanted to be really
agnostic to applications.
It turns out, unsurprisingly,
a lot of your building
HTTP-based applications.
And you want a way to get
HTTP into your clusters.
So, again, you asked,
and we listened.
We built a new API
object called Ingress.
Ingress will allow
you to describe
a map based on host headers
or based on URL paths that
will take incoming
HTTP traffic and route
it to various Kubernetes
service backends.
So now, again, you can
build much micro services.
You could have your contact
manager as one application,
and you can have your email
box as another application,
and they can come in
through the same URL
and be spread out into
these different services.
This is literally
how Google operates.
We have implementations of
the Ingress API against GCE.
There's one against
Amazon that's
being developed right
now-- HA Proxy and Inginx.
What this really means is if
you want to run on-premise,
you can totally do it.
You can run HA Proxy
on your premise.
You can pick up
your application.
You can move it to GCE, and you
can get all the awesome power
of the GCE load balancer API,
if you saw that talk yesterday.
The reality of these
cloud provider APIs
is sometimes
they're complicated.
And if you learn the
GCE load balancer API
and then you want
to move to Amazon,
then you have to learn the
Amazon load balancer API.
And these two things can't
be any more different.
And you don't want
to deal with that.
That's a mess.
That's coupling.
So Ingress gives you a
way to couple from that.
The next thing
people talk about,
and Rich mentioned this with
respect to his stuff at WePay,
is Secrets.
You've got to authenticate
your applications.
You've got to give them
access to a secured something.
I don't care what it is.
Maybe it's an NSH key.
Maybe it's an API token.
Maybe it's a password
in plain text in a file.
You have a need to
access these things.
But we've all read the
12-Factor Manifesto, right?
12 Factor says, you
put your configuration
in the environment.
Well, Kubernetes
is the environment.
This is where you're
getting stuff.
So we are now giving you an
API to manage your Secrets
through our unified
Kubernetes API
through the same cube control
command line interface,
through the same YAML objects,
with the same semantics
as everything else.
You inject them into your
application late bound.
You write it in you API.
You run your application.
You join these two things
at the very last second.
They are written in a tmpfs.
So you never write to the desk.
They're only in memory.
And you can then access them as
files or environment variables
from your application.
So let's do a live demo.
Can we switch to demo screen?
Thank you.
All right.
So like everything else, there's
a little bit of YAML behind it.
I'm going to go off
and create a Secret.
It is called My Secret Password.
It is a type opaque.
It's not in TLS
certificate or anything
that we might know about.
The username and password
are [? Bay64 ?] here,
simply so we can stick binary
data into this YAML file.
Like everything else, we
just run kubectl create -f.
It goes off and
creates my Secret.
Now I'm going to go
of and create a pod.
Again, all this pod
does is go to sleep,
but it mounts this Secret.
You see the volume Secret here?
It's going to mount it
at this /data directory.
So I'll just create the pod.
And the pod is there,
and it's running.
And again, I'm going
to shell into this
just to show you what we've got.
So if I look in /data now, I've
got this virtual directory that
is password and username.
So I can cat slash data, and
you can see that it's me.
And I can show you my password.
And when I log out of
that pod, that's it.
My pod's now running.
If that was an SSH
key, I could then
use that credentials to
get into the other peers,
or I could use it as an
API token to go into Twilio
or whatever I needed it to be.
You can switch back to
the main slides now.
Demo number two!
[APPLAUSE]
So I've only got a
few minutes left.
And I wanted to talk about
some of the things we've done
and are doing around performance
and scalability of Kubernetes.
We started 1.0, and we said
Kubernetes runs on 100 nodes.
And 100's a kind of
underwhelming number, right?
People said, Google, what
are you doing-- 100 nodes?
And the truth is, I'm going
to look out in this audience.
I'm not going do a survey.
But how many of you--
think in your head.
How many of you have more than
100 serving nodes right now?
I don't need to see hands.
It's not that many people.
But we heard.
People said, actually, there
are enough people out there
that need more than 100.
Then we decided we were
going to ramp it up.
So the first thing we did is we
defined an SLO, a Service Level
Objective.
And we said, we're not
going to ramp it up
unless we can do it fast, right?
So we set our objective 99%
of all of our API calls return
in less than one
second, and 99% of pods
start up in less
than five seconds.
And that has to be true on
a fully loaded cluster--
the first pod and the last pod.
And then we use that to
test how high we can go.
In Kubernetes 1.2,
I'm happy to say,
we're doing more than 1,000
nodes at more than 30,000 pods
in a given cluster, with our
API server meeting this SLO.
Now, if you don't
mind about the SLO,
you can probably double or
even triple those numbers,
and things will get
a little bit slower.
But this is where we are
with 1.2-- 1,000 nodes.
Now, all those people
who thought, yeah,
I have more than 100 nodes, do
you have more than 1,000 nodes?
I bet there's a very,
very small number of you
out there, which is fine.
When you need it, when
your startup hits at gold,
we're there for you.
Other things we've
done in the 1.2
release-- we revamped
our cube proxy
system, which is the backbone of
our virtual IP services model.
In the 1.0 and 1.1 release,
it did a user space copy,
which we knew was
a little bit slower
and was going to be
limiting to scalability.
In 1.2, it never
moves to user space.
It's purely done in kernel.
Man, is it fast.
For the demo that
we did the keynote,
we were getting
ready to get set up,
and we were realizing
that the load
testers were causing problems.
And the first thing
that we did was
we switched to the
IP tables proxy,
and all the problems were gone.
So if I didn't believe
it before, that's it.
Additionally, in 1.2 massive
reduction in the usage of CPU
and memory that our own
components use on the system
this for x number comes
from the guy's Red Hat.
So don't take my word for it.
This means there's
more memory and CPU
left for you to run
your applications.
We want to be as slim as
we possibly can be for you.
Now, this, of course, isn't
good enough, so what's next?
1.3-- we're planning
to massively increase
the scale again.
I don't want to talk numbers
just yet, but it'll be big.
We're talking about moving
to a binary encoded protocol.
JSON, it turns
out, kind of slow.
When we ran a profile
against our system,
the number one hit was
JSON marshal and unmarshal.
So we're going to move to
a binary encoded protocol.
You'd still be JSON
there if you wanted,
but our
component-to-component stuff
will all be done through
[? Protoba ?] and GRPC.
We also are adding a bunch of
caching and parallelization
in our scheduler.
So our scheduler throughput
will be massively faster.
It will be massively
more scalable.
Then you can see here our graph
from our current performance
metrics.
We're publishing a
blog post on this.
I'm not sure if it's out yet.
But it'll be soon.
And you'll be able to
read a lot more about what
we've done with performance and
scalability on Kubernetes 1.2.
All of this is
available right now.
Kubernetes 1.2 is in the
middle of rolling out
to GKE right now.
In fact, it might be
done this very day.
If you want it, you can go
to your container engine.
You can run the upgrade
command, and you
can get all this goodness
right here, right now.
[APPLAUSE]
So, all that said, we
have a ton of work to do.
We have 800 man years
of work on our roadmap.
I'm not even kidding,
and that's if we only
do the things we know about.
Kubernetes is an open project.
We built up from
the very beginning
to be open source, open ideas,
open standards, open community.
We do everything in the public.
If anybody here has clicked
that Watch icon in GitHub
on the Kubernetes repo,
I feel bad for you,
because there is
so much going on.
It's exciting.
I'm passionate and
excited about this.
We need your help.
We need people who
are using this thing
to come in and
tell us what works,
what doesn't work, what do
you need out of the system,
because we are listening.
We want to make it
work for you guys.
So you can see here,
we've got our URL.
The code, of courses,
is on GitHub.
All of us hang out on
Slack all the time.
Come and ask us questions.
We have dedicated
people who sit there
and answer user support
questions all day.
We're also on Stack Overflow,
and we're on Twitter.
You can find Brendan and
myself and many other people
there, and come and
ask us questions.
So I understand we are not
doing it to a Q&A session now.
But at the end of
these sessions,
we will all be hanging
out in the Playground.
We'll grab a quick bite to
eat, and we'll be out there
to do Q&A, talk to people.
Come tell us your story.
Tell us what worked,
what didn't work.
I want to hear from you.
So thank you all very much.
[APPLAUSE]